SAFETY AND THEIR LIVES AS THIS
BRUTAL WAR MARCHES ON.
OUR NEXT GUEST WAS ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE.
ANASTASIA FLED FROM KHERSON
WHERE SHE WAS BORN AND RAISED
AND SHE JOINS US NOW FROM ODESA,
FOR HER SAFETY AND SECURITY
WE'RE NOT USING HER LAST NAME,
NOR ARE WE GOING TO SUCCESS HER
FAMILY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING BRAVE ENOUGH
TO TALK TO US TODAY.
I WANT TO START BY ASKING YOU
ABOUT THE DAY WHERE FIVE RUSSIAN
OFFICERS CAME INTO THE APARTMENT
THAT YOU LIVED IN WITH YOUR
BOYFRIEND, THEY TOOK YOUR
PHONES.
THEY LOOKED THROUGH YOUR PHONE
AND SAW THAT YOU'D WRITTEN
THINGS ON SOCIAL MEDIA THAT WERE
NEGATIVE ABOUT RUSSIA AND THEY
ASKED IF YOU WERE A REPORTER.
WHAT WAS THAT DAY LIKE, AND HOW
FRIGHTENED WERE YOU?
>> YEAH, IT WAS JUST A NORMAL
DAY, AND THERE WAS A MOMENT WHEN
WE HEARD THAT SOMEONE STARTED TO
KNOCK ON ALL THE DOORS IN OUR
FIVE-FLOOR HOUSE.
AND WE DIDN'T EVEN REALIZE THAT
WE CAN BE THE ONES THEY WERE
LOOKING FOR.
THE REASON WAS ACTUALLY THE CCTV
CAMERA ON OUR BALCONY, AND THEY
WANTED TO FIND TO WHOM IT
BELONGS TO AND WHY IT IS THERE.
SO THEY CAME TO OUR APARTMENT
AND THEY FIRST ASKED FOR OUR
DOCUMENTS AND WHY WE NEEDED THAT
CAMERA, AND THEN THEY WANTED TO
SEE OUR PHONES.
WE WERE VERY AFRAID BECAUSE
FIRST OF ALL, WE KNOW THAT THEY
KIDNAP PEOPLE HERE.
THEY CAN KILL SOME PEOPLE AND
THEY CAN ALSO EVEN DO SOMETHING
TERRIBLE WITH THE WOMEN, YOU
KNOW, LIKE RAPING, ET CETERA.
FIRST OF ALL, I WROTE A MESSAGE
TO MY BROTHER ABOUT WHAT IS
GOING ON AND TO MY HR TO LET HER
KNOW THAT IF I DON'T APPEAR WHY
IT HAPPENS.
I DIDN'T WANT TO LET MY PARENTS
KNOW ABOUT IT BECAUSE I DIDN'T
WANT THEM TO STRESS AT THAT
MOMENT, AND THEN, YOU KNOW, THEY
CAME INTO OUR APARTMENT AND THEY
STARTED TO LOOK FOR SOMETHING
FORBIDDEN, LIKE WEAPONS, I DON'T
KNOW, MAYBE THEY THOUGHT WE ARE
SOME KIND OF SECRET AGENTS
FOLLOWING THEM FROM THE CAMERA,
AND THEN THEY STARTED TO ASK
ABOUT WHAT THEY FOUND IN OUR
PHONES.
I ERASED ALL THE PHOTOS AND
VIDEOS SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
WAR FROM MY PHONE, AND FROM THE
BIN, AND ACTUALLY THEY STARTED
TO READ ALL DIFFERENT
CONVERSATIONS WITH OTHER PEOPLE,
AND THEY STARTED TO QUESTION ME
IF I'M A JOURNALIST, WHO I AM,
ET CETERA.
THEY DIDN'T BELIEVE THAT WE
ATTENDED THE MANIFESTATIONS FOR
FREE.
THEY ASKED US, LIKE, THREE
TIMES, ARE YOU SURE NOBODY PAID
YOU.
WE SAID NO.
AND THEY SAID WE DON'T BELIEVE
YOU JUST ON YOUR PERSONAL
INITIATIVE.
THAT'S HOW THEY ARE.
THEY REALLY DON'T BELIEVE IT'S
POSSIBLE.
AND THEN IN THE END, THEY WERE
JUST NOT HAPPY ABOUT ALL THE
HATE FOR RUSSIANS IN MY PHONE,
AND THEY DECIDED TO GIVE ME A
NEW LIFE SO THEY ERASED
COMPLETELY ALL IN MY iPHONE,
THEY ASKED FOR THE PASSWORD FOR
MY APPLE I.D. AND FORMATTED IT
SO WHEN YOU OPEN IT, YOU JUST
SEE, LIKE, FOR THE FIRST TIME
WHEN YOU BUY A PHONE, YOU SEE
HELLO IN DIFFERENT LANGUAGES,
AND FROM MY BOYFRIEND, THEY SAW
THAT HE WROTE TO SOMEONE IN
SOCIAL MEDIA LIKE SLAVO, WHICH
IS GLORY TO UKRAINE, AND ONE
SOLDIER SAYS WHY YOU DO THIS,
ARE YOU NAZI.
>> ANASTASIA.
>> YEAH.
>> I'M GOING TO INTERRUPT YOU
BECAUSE I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
FLEEING.
I KNOW IT WAS FRIGHTENING, AND
ONE OF THEM WAS PLAYING WITH HIS
GUN, ONE WAS NOT TOO BAD WITH
YOU, BUT ONE WAS QUITE
THREATENING.
YOU CAN EXPLAIN TO ME, BUT I
BELIEVE THEY LEFT AND YOU WERE
SO FRIGHTENED THAT YOU AND YOUR
BOYFRIEND PACKED UP AND YOU WENT
TO STAY WITH A FAMILY MEMBER AND
YOU HID FOR A WEEK, AND YOU
DIDN'T USE YOUR PHONES BECAUSE
YOU WERE AFRAID OF BEING
TRACKED.
JUST EXPLAIN.
>> YES, AFTER THEY LEFT OUR
HOME, THEY CALLED US BACK IN ONE
HOUR AND SAID WE SHOULD GO TO
THEIR OFFICE THE NEXT DAY AND WE
DECIDED TO ESCAPE.
SO WE WERE HIDING LIKE FOR ONE
WEEK.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW THE ADDRESS
WHERE WE WERE, SO AFTER ONE
WEEK, WE COULD FIND A WAY HOW TO
FLED FROM KHERSON.
IT WAS VERY VERY FRIGHTENING.
WE TOOK VERY BASIC THINGS WITH
US, AND EVERY TIME WHEN WE
PASSED RUSSIAN BLOCK, IT WAS
REALLY, I DON'T KNOW, MY HEART
WAS JUST BLEEDING BECAUSE EVERY
TIME I THOUGHT IT'S JUST -- IT'S
OUR LAST MINUTES.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE RUSSIAN
FLAGS EVERYWHERE IN KHERSON.
>> I KNOW.
I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THAT.
ANASTASIA, WHAT DID YOU THINK
WOULD HAPPEN AS YOU DESCRIBED
IT, YOUR HEART WAS READY TO
EXPLODE BECAUSE YOU WERE
TERRIFIED THAT YOU WERE GOING TO
BE CAUGHT.
WHAT DID YOU THINK WOULD HAPPEN
IF YOU WERE FOUND BY THE
SOLDIERS?
>> I THOUGHT WE WOULD BE SHOT OR
KIDNAPPED AND BEFORE LEAVING
KHERSON, I WAS THINKING ABOUT
WHAT I WOULD DO IF I FIND MYSELF
SOMEWHERE IN SIBERIA OR THE
EASTERN RUSSIA BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT THEY DO NOW WITH PEOPLE WHO
DON'T LIKE RUSSIAN POLITICS, FOR
EXAMPLE, AND I WAS THINKING -- I
WAS LIKE BUILDING A PLAN WHERE I
WOULD GO, HOW I WOULD SPEAK TO
PEOPLE IN ORDER TO LEAVE RUSSIA.
>> I KNOW, AND YOU WERE STUDYING
ABROAD.
YOU WERE LIVING A LIFE.
UNTIL THIS HAPPENED, YOU WERE
HAPPY LIVING WITH YOUR
BOYFRIEND.
>> YES.
>> WE'VE GOT PICTURES OF YOU AT
ONE OF THE PROTESTS AFTER THE
RUSSIAN TROOPS ARRIVED.
AND I KNOW YOU HAVE FRIEND AND
PEOPLE YOU ARE CLOSE TO IN
KHERSON.
I HAVE ABOUT A MINUTE LEFT,
ANASTASIA, HOW ARE THEY DOING,
AND WHAT DO YOU WANT PEOPLE WHO
ARE WATCHING THIS TO UNDERSTAND
ABOUT WHAT UKRAINIANS ARE GOING
THROUGH?
>> WHAT WE ARE GOING THROUGH,
BEFORE I HAD FRIEND FROM SYRIA
AND AFGHANISTAN WHO TOLD ME
ABOUT HOW THEY FLED THEIR
COUNTRIES AND I REALLY COULDN'T
UNDERSTAND THE FEELINGS THAT
THEY HAD AT THAT MOMENT, EVEN
THOUGH THEY TOLD ME ABOUT ALL OF
THIS.
BUT WHEN I FELT THIS ON MY OWN
SKIN, I REALIZED THAT EVEN
UKRAINIANS WHO ARE NOW ABROAD
AND WHO DIDN'T HEAR ALL THE
EXPLOSIONS SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THE WAR, THEY WILL NEVER
UNDERSTAND HOW IT IS.
EVERY MOMENT IS LIKE, YOU KNOW,
WHEN YOU ARE IN THE AMUSEMENT
PARK, YOU ARE ON THE MOST
DANGEROUS, LET'S SAY,
ATTRACTION, AND YOU GO UP, YOU
KNOW NOW YOU WILL FA